>>Stephanie: My name is Stephanie Magin and
I'm on the Leadership Development team as
part of Google EDU and I manage a program
called, "Managing Your Energy," of which many
of you are alumni. Exciting thing is that
we have the man behind the content here--
[man coughs]
to talk to us today, so we're really excited.
I just wanted to mention, too, as I was kind
of running the numbers this morning, over
1200 Google-, Googlers, so over that number
of people here have been exposed to this content.
Tony Schwartz, like I said, is kind of like
the man behind the, you know, the class that
we do here called Managing Your Energy; co-author
of the book that spurred that, which was The
Power of Full Engagement.
Managing energy, not time, so helping us as
well as Google to, to kind of go through that
paradigm shift and he's to talk to us today
about his new book that came out in May. And
it is already a bestseller on The New York
Times and Wall Street Journal called, Why
the Way We're Working Isn't Working. And he's
gonna share some kind of new research with
us today that gets at a lot of that we already
know, but kind of looking at it in a new way.
And we're also gonna get to hear from some
of the alumni of the class about the changes
that you guys have been able to, to make through
exposure to the content, so that's gonna be
fun. So, Tony is the founder and CEO of The
Energy Project, which helps individuals in
organizations increase their capacity through
the science of, of higher performance.
So, all of this stuff that we're going to
be hearing today is based on science and research,
which is great for us data, data driven Googlers.
So, just really quick, background on Tony,
started his career as a, as journalist and
had lots of different kind of journalistic
and editorial positions, working at such publications
as The New York Times, Newsweek, The New York
and Esquire magazines and Fast Company, and
he also co-authored the number one, worldwide
best-selling book on The Art of the Deal,
which he co-wrote with Donald Trump. So, without
further ado, let's welcome Tony Schwartz.
[applause]
>>Tony: Thanks, Stephanie. Hi, Googlers. It's
good to be here with you. How's everybody
doing?
>>female audience member 1: Great.
>>Tony: Good? All right. So, it's, it's, I
wanna see if this resonates with you. I want
you to think about yourself as "Johnny," in
this little story I'm gonna tell you and I
want you to s-, tell me if at the end it,
it resonates with your own experience in your
own life. So, it's 7 AM somewhere in Mountain
View, or wherever you happen to live--
[baby crying]
and you, Johnny has just woken up and he needs
to get downstairs for breakfast by 7:15, out
the door to school by 7:30. But on this particular
morning, he doesn't get downstairs and his
father is downstairs making his breakfast
cause he's a modern dad.
Mother has already gotten off to work. Goes
to the bottom of the stairs, yells up to Johnny,
"Johnny, your breakfast is getting cold. You're
gonna be late. Hurry on down." And Johnny
says, "I'm not going to school today."
So his father trots up the stairs, he sits
down on the foot of Johnny's bed. Johnny's
got the covers pulled up all the way to his
chin. Says to him, "Johnny, gimme three good
reasons why you're not gonna go to school
today."
Johnny says, "Fine. Number one: I don't like
the kids. Number two: The kids don't like
me. And number three: It's too hard."
Father says, "Ok, Johnny, now I'm gonna give
you three good reasons why you are going to
school today. Number one: I'm your father
and I'm telling you, you're going to school
today. Number two: You're 47 years old.
[laughter]
And number three: You're the principal of
the school."
[laughter]
So this is, this is where we find ourselves,
right? You know, there are those days where
you'd rather stay there with covers, you know,
with the cover right up to your chin and not
get out of bed. I mean, how many of you would
say that in the last two or three years that
demand in your life has been higher than it's
ever been before? How many would say that?
Ok, so that's almost the whole room.
Over a thousand people, by the way. How many
of you would say, given that these last couple
of years have been so intense, and, of course,
with the economy the way it is and all that,
there's someone, some reason why, you know,
it's been harder the last couple of years?
How many of you would say that you would expect,
given all that, things are starting to look
a little better now, the bar in the upcoming
year will finally be lowered? Hahahaha.
We got one person and he just lost his job.
[laughter]
But everybody else says, "No, no." Here's
the $64,000 question: You're, you're demand
is going up, you think it will continue to
go up, how many of you expect your capacity
to meet that demand to rise right along with
the demand? So, that's not good, right?
That's not good and that's really the, the
absolute core. We really never, in human history,
have had this particular challenge before,
and here's the challenge. The challenge is
that this is the volume of your demand in
the vertical axis here, this is the, this
is your age in the horizontal axis, so from
early to late, how many of you are getting
older?
[laughter]
About half? So, so, the demand in your life
starts to go up and sure enough, and the great
thing is, that almost no matter what you do
to yourself, and do to your body, up until
a certain age your capacity stays out ahead
of your demand. But then in a certain moment,
it peaks out and that moment actually, physically,
is about 30 years old. About 30 years old.
So, actually, we're-, for rare for my talks,
in this room there's some people who are still
got the capacity out at the demand, but guess
what? That won't last forever. And then what
happens is, the, there is a point at which
this crosses and that's a bad moment. That's
a bad moment because all kinds of terrible
things happen when demand exceeds your capacity.
And when I say this has never been the case
before in human history, our capacity, given
the demands we've had, has always basically
been sufficient until the last ten or twenty
or thirty years, to meet the demands we're
facing. And, of course, you know all the reasons
why the demand has gone up so high relative
to our capacity because you're responsible
for most of them. You know, at Google.
Meaning it's the volume of information now
available to us and flooding into our lives.
It's the number of ways we can communicate
with each other. It's the difficulty of being
in a situation where you don't have to communicate.
All those things are going on and they're
affecting it. So, the problem is that in the
face of this rising demand, we don't stop
to ask the question, "What's the cost?"
And we have lived since the Industrial Revolution
with a certain paradigm about how work should
happen in a modern, in a, in a market economy,
and it's that "more, bigger, faster" is the
way to go. But the premise that I operate
on and that I think we're beginning to see
progressive leaders and progressive companies
begin to embrace is that "more, bigger, faster"
leads to value that is narrow, shallow, and
short-term. Could there be a better example
in the, the world today than BP, right?
That was all, entirely, about "more, bigger,
faster." What about Toyota? It was about,
even they acknowledge, BP may not fully acknowledge
this yet, but Toyota acknowledges that "more,
bigger, faster" was the problem. Toyota b-,
I, Mr. Toyota himself.
So, this is not a way we can go and part of
the problem is that we don't have the capacity
to go "more, bigger, faster" without all kinds
of consequences. And the, the reason we can
continue to operate as if we do, is that we
take capacity for granted. If there's more
to do, we'll simply expand our capacity, and
we'll be able to do it. So when I ask you
the question, "Do you expect your capacity
to rise right along with your demand?" you're
brought up a little short.
It's like, what do you, what you mean by that?
I, I'm, I'm not quite sure wh-, I never thought
about capacity before. I have a lot of skills
or a lot of talents. What's this thing with
capacity? Well, capacity is the fuel in your
tank.
Capacity it what makes it possible for you
to bring your skill and talent to life. So,
without capacity, no matter how much skill
and talent you have, and you have a ton, it's
not gonna be able, it's not gonna be possible
for you to produce it. And the other thing
is that though our resources are finite, we
treat them as if they're infinite. And I'm
talking about our inner resources. This same,
exact issue exists in the planet, doesn't
it?
We have made the assumption for a long, long
time that it doesn't matter how we spend down
the planet's resources because there's plenty
more where that came from. Well, those of
us who are even half clued in know that's
nonsense. And that in a world in which we
do not find ways to discover either alternative
resources or to renew the existing resources
after we use them, we're in all kinds of trouble.
The same exact thing is true for us as human
beings, personally, internally. So, up until
now, we've used as the vehicle to meet rising
demand, we've used time, right? So when there's
more to do, we simply invest more hours.
But the problem with that is this: there ain't
any more time. You got 168 hours in your week,
you're never gonna have another hour, and
almost everybody in this room has a dance
card that's full. Nobody is looking for ways
to fill their free time, are they? So that's
a problem. That's one of the capacity problems.
We have assumed that the way that you can
get more done is to put in more hours, but
there aren't any more hours.
And that's where this other way of looking
at the world really evolved for us. And that's
because energy can be expanded. Now, look,
there, energy can't be expanded, actually,
as you know, but energy can be converted from
one form to another form. So in practical,
in practical terms for you as a human being,
you have the potential to bring more energy
to the table depending on how you manage and
cultivate your energy, and you can regularly
renew your energy. And here's the thing: time
is outside you.
Time is something which over you, ultimately,
have no control. It moves past you like a
train moving off into the distance, but energy
is inside you. You have the power to influence
your own energy. So as soon as you begin to
understand what energy really is all about,
you're in a whole different kind of situation
in terms of being able to take more control
of your life. So, energy, we define energy,
the folks here who teach it at Google, define
energy in pure, simple physics terms.
Energy is the capacity to do work. More energy,
more capacity. So the question is, can we
get you, can I help you and can the folks
here help you to systematically build the
energy available to you? That's really the
issue. And there are four kinds of energy.
Those of you who been through the class know
that there are four sources of energy that
a human being needs.
A car can run on gas or, you know, more recently,
a car can run on electricity, but a human
being actually needs four. So you need physical
energy, quantity. You need emotional energy.
That's a particular quality of energy. You
need mental energy -- that's the focus of
your energy. And you need spiritual energy,
which we're -- the energy of the human spirit,
which we define simply as the energy derived
from the experience that what you do, really
matters wherever you do it. Or the alignment
of your energy, meaning that your energy is
aimed toward a very unconscious goal. So,
there they are -- four sources of energy.
If you can recruit all of those and regularly
renew them, you're gonna fire on all cylinders,
but, but we don't. Why don't we? Because it
takes consciousness to do that.
And really what I think I'm talking about,
at the profound level, is an evolutionary
leap in consciousness. I can get away with
saying that at Google. An evolutionary leap
in consciousness to move toward the kind of
intentionality that's now required to meet
the demands that we face. So, fierce intentionality,
I use the word fierce, obviously, advisably
because there is so much about our lives that
happens habitually and automatically and outside
our conscious minds and conscious intention.
So, to really seize back control of your destiny,
you need to br-, apply a kind of intentionality
that's never been required of you before.
And this is an intentionality, listen, we
have, we have invested enormous energy in
the world, and Google is a wonderful and positive
example what happens when you invest energy
in understanding and managing better and more
efficiently the external world.
Wonderful, look at what you've produced. It's
extraordinary and there are, you have fellow
organizations and companies that have also
done great, great work about mastering the
external world. But we have vastly, vastly
undervalued and underinvested in understanding
and managing the inner world. And the inner
world -- let's put aside, you know, whatever
new age connotations or psychodynamic connotations
that has -- the inner world is where these
sources of energy are being produced. They're
coming from inside you.
They're coming from inside you. So to know
about them is the, is the first necessity
to understand what's going on, effectively
inside you, is the first critical necessity
in being able to change the way you manage
it. We have to start to value something that
has been invisible to most of us forever.
And I like to say that the inner life is our
own personal China and India.
Meaning, it's the place where we have the
biggest potential for growth, where we ought
to be making the biggest investment of our
time and energy because there's so much untapped
there. It is terra incognita. It's a vast,
that inner landscape is a vast, untrafficked,
unmet territory. Bob Keegan at Harvard, who's
a wonderful thinker about development says
that we are the most over informed and under
reflective people in the history of the world.
That's a scary thing. But the big, the, the
thing that's so profound to me, not only to
you, but for organizations, is that the future
competitive advantage all lies in your ability
to master this inner world. So that could
be seen as intimidating or it could be seen
as a wonderful challenge and opportunity.
I choose to see it as the latter.
So, here's from a, from a, from, from a technological
perspective, the way I look at it is that
our hardware, our hardwiring, has not changed
over the last several hundred years. There's
nothing's changed. Kids think that their brains
operate differently, and they can do more
things than their parents can do. It's nonsense.
Their, their brains have not changed in that
way, or not so substantially, but the demands
on our hardware have increased so significantly.
And there, it turns out that there is a science
and a technology to, that makes it possible.
In effect, what there is is, there's a, there's
the potential for an upgraded operating system
-- the ability to use a whole different kind
of software to run your own operating system,
your internal operating system than there
was even ten, twenty, thirty years ago. Here's
why we don't know much about it, among other
things. We don't know much about it because
[man coughs]
it's multidisciplinary, and we live in a world
of specialists. And the power if it is that
it, the physical dimension affects the emotional
dimension and then the mental dimension affects
the physical dimension. And all of these are
intermingled, but the folks who are expert
about any given one them don't talk to each
other.
That's the work we've tried to do, is to try
to bring together a series of disciplines
and the research from those disciplines to
make it possible for you to have a life that
is not only productive, but is satisfying
and sustainable. Now, why is it? Why is it
that this isn't working? Well, this is what
we think the core understanding and what I'm
gonna spend the rest of my time with you talking
about is, is that we made an assumption that
we should operate in the same way computers
do. Meaning, at high speeds, continuously,
for long periods of time, running multiple
programs at the same time.
But those of you been through any part of
this work know that that's not the way, and
some of you just know it instinctively. That's
not the way we're designed. We are designed
to be rhythmic beings. We're designed to pulse
between expending energy, between expending
energy and regularly renewing your energy,
and we don't do either of those very well.
Now here's, that's interesting. It's no surprise
to you to think, "I don't do so well at renewing
my energy because renewal gets no respect
in the world we live in." Right?
Renewal, rest, recovery -- that's for slackers.
That's not for Googlers. Googlers spend energy,
slackers renew energy. So that's not so much
surprising, but it turns out that we don't
do very well at spending energy either. Meaning,
we spend tons of it, but we don't spend it
in efficient, productive, useful ways or at
least not relative to our potential. So I
wanna kind of dive in a little bit on both
sides of this equation and help you, see if
you can kind of take a different perspective
on the way you're doing each of these two
things -- renewing energy, spending energy.
So, let's start with the most important component
of renewal. I see a gentleman in the back
of the room yawning. He's, that's my cousin.
He's doing that for me to lead me to this
point, which is, there is, I'm gonna, I wanna
sort of try and explode several myths about
renewal because there are so many myths about
the, the role of renewal. And the first one
has to do with sleep because sleep is the
single most important renewal activity and
the single most undervalued renewal activity;
something we find a hundred ways to rationalize
not doing enough of. So the, the myth is:
I don't need much sleep. And this wonderful
quote from Thomas Roth at the Henry Ford Sleep
Disorder Center,
[reads quote]
"The percentage of the population
who need less than five hours of sleep per
night,
rounded to a whole number,
is zero"
So, what we know in reality is that, actually,
97.5 percent of the population needs at least
seven to eight hours of sleep. Ninety-five
percent of us needs seven to eight hours.
Two and a half percent of us need more than
eight hours and two and a half percent of
us lead, need less than eight hours, seven
to eight hours, ok? So, 97.5 percent of the
people sitting in this room today need to
sleep a minimum of seven to eight hours in
order to be fully rested. How many people
in this room do not consistently sleep seven
to eight hours? Ok, so that's about 80 percent
of the room. That's pretty interesting. That's
pretty interesting.
What's the reality, I'm sorry, what's the
rationalization that most of us use? Well,
the rationalization most of us use for not
sleeping that much is number one: I don't
have time, right? I don't have time; I've
got too much to do. And then the related one,
which is the myth, is this: is, oops, I guess
it's not quite yet. The related one, the related
one is: If I sleep an hour longer, and this
something you either say to yourself consciously
or maybe unconsciously, if I sleep an hour
longer, I'll get an extra hour of work done.
Right? It gives me another hour in my day.
I'm sorry, if I sleep it, one less hour, I'll
have it.
That was pretty off. If I sleep one less hour,
I'll have one more hour that I can do work
in, right? Well, that's nonsense. Why? Because
when you have insufficient sleep, the costs
to you cognitively are extraordinary. I'm
gonna get to that in just a moment, but here's
how important sleep is and again, some of
you have, some of you may remember this study.
But it, to me, is the most powerful study
ever done about the importance of sleep, and
it was done on rats.
So, this guy, Allan Rechtschaffen at the University
of Chicago, probably one of the two or three
leading sleep researchers in the world, did
this research, this very famous research,
which he, which he deprived these rats of
sleep for as long as it took till he got the
conclusion he wanted. And what happened is
that after, and this is all, every one of
these really interesting, what happened is
after two or three days, they were expending
twice the energy that they would if they had
had enough sleep.
Now, th-, let's just assume the parallels
exist for human beings. Because he took these
rats all the way to death, this experience
has not been re-, redone with human beings;
little bit of an ethical problem to do it
with human being, right? But, but, think about
this. In order to stay up, you have to seek
an alternative source of energy, so what you
do is you, the system naturally responds by
expending more energy. What it means is, whatever
energy you're expending when you are sleep
deprived, is energy not available to do the
things you might otherwise do, other than
trying to stay up.
That's interesting. Then the next thing that
happens is they overeat; same reason. They're
trying to get some form of energy in the form
of glucose, so in order to get that, to overcome
the ab-, absence of sleep, they overeat. And
worse yet, the hormone, leptin, is produced
during sleep, primarily and leptin is the
thing that tells you that you are satiated
when you are eating and therefore, you lose
recognition of the fact that you are, you
aren't hungry when you are not sleeping enough.
And that's why there's such a powerful correlation
between obesity and, and, and la-, lack of
sleep. And they lose control of their body
temperature. You know how powerful it would
be, how, how devastating it would be if you
had a temp-, a body temperature of 97 degrees
or a body temperature of 106.
Those, that's not good and then they begin
to develop sores that won't heal and 17 to
21 days these rats are dead. Now, the reality
is, as a human being, you would be, that you
wouldn't be necessarily, d-, you wouldn't
necessarily be dead after sev-, we know that
people are not dead, human beings are not
dead after 17 to 21 days of sleep, but you
are, you would be completely incapable of
functioning after 17 to 21 days; in fact,
long, long before that.
But the really interesting thing about this
study is he goes back and he does the same
study, except this time with a different set
of rats. Poor rats. With a different set of
rats, he deprives them of food for 17 days,
ok? How the rats doing at the end of 17 days?
What's the one word that best describes how
those rats are doing at the end of 17 days?
[audience gives mixed answers]
Alive. Hungry. I'll take either one. They're
fine, but they're hungry. What is the message
there? Because if there's one message I could
leave you with if I stopped right now, it
would be this one: Sleep is more important
than food. That's a big deal. Sleep is more
important than food and yet, we don't treat
it that way. So when you're depriving yourself
of sleep, we think this one hour of, of extra
sleep of le-, of
[pause]
Yeah, ok. Good.
[tech member says something]
I'm really kin-, I just had a panic that that
slide was as, as wrong as I had been a moment
ago.
[laughter]
We have this assumption that one hour more
of sleep will add one hour of productivity
to your day, but the reality is that even
very small amounts of sleep deprivation profoundly
influence not only your physical sense of
well-being and your emotional balance, but
your cognitive capacity. How many of you have
a job here in which you're required to use
your brain?
[laughter]
Only about two-thirds, which is kind of interesting.
Yeah, that's a kind of important organ here
at Google, but here's some of the things that
happen if you sleep less than seven to eight
hours. So, Cheri Mah at Stanford, right down
the block, Cheri Mah's done all these studies
with athletes, and now she's found, just recently,
some of you may have seen this, that sprinters,
when they are asked for a six week period
to sleep ten hours or more, turn out to perform
dramatically better at their sprints.
She's done this across six, seven, eight different
sports and showed that if you sleep more hours,
this sounds crazy to you, ten hours. When's
the last time you slept ten hours, but it
dramatically influences their performance.
So, you're saying to yourself, "Well, you
know, fine. A sprinter, I mean, they're physically
exhausted, yeah they need more sleep." Trust
me, I'm gonna get to another study at the
end of the, my talk today that's gonna show
you that it's no different that cognitive
capacity, the ability to, to think, is profoundly
influenced, equally influenced by how much
you've slept.
This is, to me, quite extraordinary that subjects
who were sleeping less than six hours a night
for two weeks and I'll bet ya, how many of
you have gotten a, have had a time in your
life where you slept less than six hours a
night for a two week period? Right? Isn't
that incredible? So, look at, that's almost
everybody, look at the, the effect of it is
that it's equivalent to 48 consecutive hours
of sleep deprivation. How do you think you'd
be functioning at the end of those 48 hours?
Now, you say to yourself, "Well, that's nonsense.
I mean, come on. I know how I am at the end
of these weeks of sleeping less than six hours
a night. I'm fine. I don't have any problem."
And you know what? When they take a guy out
of a car on a highway where he's been swerving
down the highway, and they put him up and
they said, "Have you had too much to drink?"
What does that guy usually say? No. "Are you
intoxicated, sir?" No. Does he believe he's
intoxicated? No. We don't know the effect
that we have. We are in a state of denial
about the cumulative impact of insufficient
sleep. But these researchers go and actually
look at it.
So, the final one of these statistics I think
is pretty interesting is you give the pilot,
you got a pilot right here, you give the pilot
a 40 minute nap during a long haul flight
and his vigilance and, by the way, and I was
talking to this gentleman who's a pilot here
cause he's a colleague for me, of mine. I
was talking to him on the way out here and
I, actually the word he used to describe one
of the absolute, critical skills for a pilot
is vigilance. Would you agree with that? We
certainly want them to be vigilant when we're
in their planes.
Their vigilance increases 16 percent if they
have a 40-minute nap during a long haul flight,
and it drops 34 percent if they don't. They
have multiple moments of micro sleep when
they take these long haul flights without
sleep, without a nap, and they have no instances,
zero instances, of micro sleep when you give
them a 40-minute nap.
And I should tell you that when you give somebody
a 40 minute nap, they only sleep an, an average
of 26 minutes. So, in other words, the value
of getting, the value you derive from just
25 minutes, 26 minutes, of a nap is absolutely
extraordinary from a performance perspective.
And finally, this is really, you know, at
the heart of this, this is really the cen-,
central point here is that we make an assumption
that the best way to get more work done is
to work more hours.
That's the extrapolation of what I was saying
about sleep. If I have twice the amount of
work to do, I'll put in more hours. But, we're
actually much, much more productive when we
build in an intermittent renewal during the
day. This is really the heart of why I'm saying
to you that renewal is such a critical component
for your life. Not so that you can have, I
mean, it's a by-product that you get a happier
life as a result. It's a by-product that your
relationships are better, but from a pure
work perspective, it works better to build
in intermittent periods of renewal.
So, recognize this: Every human being must
renew and recover. We must do it because our
bodies go into periods of fatigue. So, if
that's the case, what do most of us do to
renew? And some of you have seen this, but
I, this is the typical way. I try to keep
my coffee pof-, coffee buzz going till the
martini buzz kicks in, right? That's the typical
way that we use to renew ourselves in the
course of the day.
Along with, by the way, activating unconsciously
our stress hormones because cortisol and adrenaline
and noradrenalin prompt a powerful surge of
energy that we use in order to stay the course
even when we would otherwise, or naturally,
go into periods of fatigue. Here's the most
profound cost of using cortisol, adrenaline,
and noradreneline--
[man coughs]
in the short term. The profound cost of using
those stress hormones to stay the course is
that they push us into a state that we know
as "fight or flight." That's what the nature
of pulling those hormones up is, and in fight
or flight the further or the more intensely
you get into that state, the more incapable
of thinking you are. So, we think less well
when that happens. So what's the alternative
to this? So, the alternative is to respect
your oscillatory nature. You are meant to
move between spending and renewing energy.
When you align with that rhythm, you become
so much more effective and sustainable.
And it's a very specific rhythm. It's a rhythm
called the ultradian rhythm that dominates
our days. And that we cannot, you cannot outwit
the ultradian rhythm any more than you can
outwit the circadian rhythm. The circadian
rhythm, you know, is day or night; sleep at
night, be awake during the day. Mess with
that and you, the consequences are significant.
At night, we sleep in cycles. You know that.
There are five cycles of sleep. You go from
light sleep to deep sleep, and if you sleep
through that cycle, you get all the benefits
of sleep and if you do it four or five times,
you get a good night's sleep. During the day,
the ultradian rhythm is the analog of that
cycle, which is called the basic rest activity
cycle. At night, it runs 90 minutes.
During the day, it runs 90 minutes, but during
the day, it's a waking rhythm. So, you move
from high physiological arousal, awakeness,
awareness, ability to do your work, slowly
down into a state of fatigue. And as I've
said, we override that rhythm with the stress
hormones, coffee, sugar, but if we simply
took time to rest and recover at the end of
those 90 minute segments, we could naturally
refuel the system without cost to ourselves.
This is a profound shift. I was talking to
Stephanie before about the "knowing-doing",
you know, paradox. I say this to you. It's
well documented by research. It's in my new
book, the research. It's on our website. You
hear it and even though maybe you've never
heard of an ultradian rhythm before, it makes
sense to you. It certainly makes sense to
almost everybody, I suspect, that, that building
and renewal would refuel the system.
But we are addicted to the pace that we're
living at and in fact, you can literally become
addicted to these stress hormones -- to adrenaline,
to cortisol and noradreneline. They are the
addiction of an immediate gratification and
it's like cocaine, you know? I mean, it's
a, it's a buzz. So, the, the question then
is if, if 90 minutes is the frequency with
which you should take a renewal break, especially
if you're working hard, how long should the
break be?
[man coughs]
How long do you think the break should be?
How long?
[audience gives mixed answers]
I wish I was talking into this. It's so much
better, but it keeps dropping. Ten minutes,
yeah, what else? As long as it takes. Now,
that's from one of the people who teaches
the work, so I'm gonna assume that's true.
[laughter]
It's not about how long you renew. It's about
how well you renew. It's not about how many
hours you invest in work during the day; it's
about how well you can work during the hours
you work. So, here's what's interesting. Again,
back to the science that undergirds this.
The myth is that fitness is a measure of how
long you can expend your energy, right?
So, you think of somebody who's in, you know,
training aerobically and that you assume that
the person can go two or three hours is the
person who is fitter than the person who can
go one hour. But actually, the definition
of fitness is the speed of your recovery.
So the fitter you are, the faster you recover.
Meaning that instead of training ourselves
to be able to expend more energy, more continuously,
which is the way we live our lives, even if
we don't always do it in fitness, we do it
in general, you wanna train yourself to recover
more quickly. Right?
So, the only way you can do that is if you
value recovery; if you value renewal. Now,
so this is how we get, this is how we get
more fit, and it's not just at the physical
level. Any muscle that you train by pushing
it past the comfort zone and then renewing,
will get stronger. If you push past the comfort
zone for too long, and you don't renew, you'll
break down the muscle.
So, this is obviously true in weight training.
It's also true in cardiovascular training,
but it's also true emotionally. It's true
that they way that you get more emotionally
resilient is you put yourselves in per-, in
a position of demand on you emotionally, and
then you recover. And the more, the more quickly
you can recover, the more resilient you are.
The more you put yourselves to the test and
then succeed at recovering without lashing
out, for example, the more resilient you've
become. So, what that requires is that you
be able to recover quickly. And what that
turns out to lead to is an amazing quickness
with which you can recover.
So, in this, what I call the time between
points, my former partner who is a sports
psychologist named Jim Laher, did this work
with athletes, with tennis players, in which
he watched them from the side of the court
trying to understand what separated the great
players from the near great players. And he
could not see any difference between them
in the way they hit the ball. It wasn't until
he started noticing how they spent the time
between points, that it, that he saw that
that is where the difference occurred. And
the reason he saw it is because one day he
had number one in the world and number two
in the world, this is going back 25 years,
on either side of the court and he noticed
that each of them was doing the same set of
sequenced activities between points, and when
he watched lesser players, they weren't doing
any of it.
And that set of sequenced activities were
all designed to build quick recovery. I'll
give you just one example. One was when the
point ended; they turned away from the net.
The reason they turned away from the net,
and by the way, nobody had taught them this,
this was natural selection, this is the difference
between the great and the near great -- the
great figure it out.
The reason they did that is because they needed
to let go, they needed to stop spending energy
where it was no longer useful. How much of
the time, how much of your energy do you spend
today on things that you can no longer influence,
in regret or frustration? It's not just building
back energy that's important in your life,
it's not just refueling energy, it's not squandering
energy on things that don't have any impact,
that you can't have an impact on.
So, that's the renewal side of the equation.
Now, I wanna switch to the energy expenditure
side of the equation for the rest of the time
we have together. So I've tried to make the
case here that renewal really matters, that's
is best done in 90 minute increments, that
the more you train it, the better you get
at it and the faster you recover, and that
this oscillatory nature is something given
to us.
It's in our hardwiring and we can either fight
it to our detriment or we can align with it
and change our lives. And I say that because
it's profoundly changed my own life and because
I've watched it profoundly change other people's
lives. As a matter of fact, who in here has
used some of this technology from having gone
through the classes to build more renewal
into your lives? Is there anybody in the,
in the? So, tell me, tell us, just tell, say,
say to the group what you've done and what
you think the impact has been?
>>male audience member 1: Well, part of it's
been letting go of work at night. So when
I leave work, work is done.
>>Tony: Yeah, and what, what's the impact
on your work? Cause the assumption would be,
what he said is when he leaves here at night,
work is over, and he no longer stays the course.
He's not checking his Blackberry and, you
know, plugging in and making phone calls,
so the assumption would be that you would
be less productive because you're probably
working on, less, fewer hours total since
you're not now checking. What's happened?
>>male audience member 1: I'm fresher, and
when I'm here I [remainder inaudible].
>>Tony: And so, he said he's fresher when
he's here. Does that mean when you're actually
working, you're more productive?
>>male audience member 1: I think so.
>>Tony: So, he, he said he's more productive.
So, again, this is my other cousin, and I
brought him here to do that testimonial. No.
So, anybody else who's had a renewal, used
this renewal understanding to their benefit?
Yeah.
>>female audience member 2: So I've started
to take a lunch break, at least a one hour
lunch break, and I think it's really helped.
Because sometimes I come back I feel [inaudible]
lunch when I come back sometimes I think that,
you know, that problem I was working on, I
have fresh insight [inaudible].
>>Tony: Yeah. So did p-, everybody hear that?
Yes, pretty much, yeah? All the way back there,
did you hear it?
>>male audience member 2: Yeah, I couldn't
hear it.
>>Tony: I will repeat it. So, this young woman
takes a regular lunch break now. She's ritualized
taking a regular lunch break, and what she
finds is that not only does it allow her to
come back to work more refreshed, but even
during the time that we, we might call it
"down time", she's finding that she has insights
and ideas that actually solve problems that
in her everyday work she wasn't able to solve.
And that's because of the movement that actually
is occurring between the left hemisphere,
which is where you are located, most of you,
in dominant, i-, i-, it's the left hemisphere
is dominant when you're doing analytic, step-by-step,
rational, logical work in the course of your
ev-, day and then as you go off to lunch,
what happens is your right hemisphere begins
to come into play, the daydreamy, more visual
side, and naturally ideas and insights rise
up.
I mean, how many of you would say that you
have your best ideas as your desks? Nobody.
That's not where we have our best ideas and
that's ver-, so, she getting de-, double bang
for her buck. She's getting both the renewal
that allows her to come back and be more focused
in the afternoon, but also the insights. Ok,
so what we do, what we do to, in the face
of so many demands where energy is, where
expending energy is required of us, what we
do is we tend to juggle those demands, don't
we? So, how many of you, for example, have
checked your email while you've been here?
You don't even have to raise your hands.
[laughter]
I don't wanna know because it's depressing.
But, answer for yourself, how many of you
checked email? How many of you have Googled
something? How many of you have updated your
status on Facebook? How many, you know, there
are whole series of things that you're doing
while listening to me that, not everybody
is, but some people are, because you're again,
saying to yourself, "Hey, I can get more things
done. I can, I can do more than just one thing.
That's what I'm capable of." But you know
what? Here's what happens as a result. This
was something that Herbert Simon, who won
the Nobel Prize in Economics, figured out
back in 1978 and that is, "What information
consumes," and that's what we put ourselves
in the face of, "What information consumes
is rather obvious. It consumes the attention
of its recipients.
Hence, a wealth of information creates a poverty
of attention." And the poverty of attention
is the energy expenditure problem right now.
It's not actually a poverty of attention,
precisely. It's a split attention that means
that you have a poverty of depth and understanding
about any given thing that you split your
attention between.
So, if you put all of your attention on one
thing, than all of those resources are devoted
to that and you get the depth from that. If
you split your attention between 11 things,
then you get one-eleventh of your attention
applied to each of the 11 things. And that
has a cost and the cost is to depth, the cost
is to quality, there are all kinds of costs
and yet we have taken this for granted. We
have assumed that this is the way; this is
another change that's occurred that we haven't
yet mastered. We've assumed this is the way
to manage a very difficult world.
You know an average person in Google and it
may be even higher, answers email 57 times
a day; checks email 57 times a day. That's
57 times that you're taking your attention
from this locus that it has to something else.
So, what's the cost? Well, we know that in
a car, when you split your attention between
talking on the phone and driving the car,
which, by the way, ought to be a reasonably
easy multitask by any normal, because it's
not two cognitive pieces.
You can get home without ever thinking about
how to get home, can't you? You know that's
all built into your system so you don't even
need to use your prefrontal cortex to help
it happen and yet, you're four times as likely
to have an accident if you're talking on the
phone and you are driving at the same time.
Which doesn't stop you, does it? How many
people here never talk on the phone while
driving? So, that number, which is about 12
out of, you know, 80 people is 12 more than
it probably was a year ago. And what we know
is that if you're texting while you're driving,
you are 23 times more likely to have an accident.
I mean, that's insane. Four times is the equivalent
of being legally intoxicated. Twenty three
times is the equivalent of being dead, while
driving. That's hard. So this is crazy. This
is a performance consequence. You don't think
it's an equivalent consequence in your everyday
work? Of course it is. Here are the key symptoms
of hyperactivity disorder -- ADHD. Often has
difficulty sustaining attention on tasks.
Doesn't listen when spoken to directly. Has
difficulty organizing tasks and activities.
Often avoids, dislikes, or is reluctant to
engage in tasks that require sustained mental
effort and is often easily distracted by extra-,
by external stimuli. Does that describe you?
Do you have three or four of those that describe
you? And if your answer is no, somebody has
five, if your answer is no, ask the person
who knows you best whether you're lying.
[laughter]
Right? This is who we are. They don't, they
don't even have a diagnosis for it; this is
normal. This is how the world ex-, exists,
but you look at those and you say, "That's
crazy. That makes no sense." What's the longest,
the, ask yourself this question, "What's the
longest you've gone without checking email
during the past month? When was the last time
that you intentionally took an hour or two
out of your day to think creatively or long
term without interruption?
And how often do you sit back for a few moments,
take a deep breath, and quiet your mind?"
Here, let's do it. Put your feet on the floor.
Put your feet on the floor. This is a special
favor. It's an extra thing that you weren't
even expected to get. This is free.
[laughter]
This is free. And by the way, you will never
have a moment where your supervisor comes
up to you and says to you, "What are you doing?
I'm noticing your breathing? You're not allowed
to do that. Why aren't you working?" No. This
is, this is one you can get away with anytime.
This is a, this is an example of the power
of recovery to occur in an incredibly short
time. I want you to breathe in through your
nose to a count of three and out through your
mouth to a count of six. I want you to do
it with your eyes closed for a little while,
and I'll bring you back to the room. In through
your nose to a count of three, out through
your mouth to a count of six. Let's do it.
[deep breathing]
Ok, you can come back to the room. Thirty
seconds. Anybody feel any difference doing
that? Is that how you normally breathe? Thirty
seconds is enough to shift your physiology
quite dramatically. If we hooked you up to
monitors, those of you who did that effectively,
and I say what I mean by that in just a sec,
those of you who did it effectively would
have had a visible movement from sympathetic
arousal, that's the "fight or flight" system,
to parasympathetic arousal.
Just 30 seconds and by the way, the better
you get at it, the more you train that recovery,
the more effectively you do recover in that
period of time. So, the lesson to this, I'm
gonna say, is, how many of you had a thought
or two or ten or thirty, during those thirty
seconds? How many had that?
You may not even have noticed, but a good
number of you. The point is that your mind
does have a mind of its own and that we need
to find a way, having looked at those ADHD
symptoms, we need to find a way if we want
to spend energy more skillfully, to recollect
our attention. We've lost control of our attention.
That's the critical problem from an energy
expenditure point of view. If your attention
is going to whatever is around you, you don't
own your attention. I'm gonna skip that one.
This is the, the conclusion that David Meyer,
the leading, the leading researcher on, on
multitasking came to about the way we currently
operate -- doing multiple things at a time.
That you can get some strategies that inclu-,
that improve your c-, your ability to handle
multiple tasks at the same time, but you can
train till you're blue in the face, and you'll
never be as good as if you just focused on
one thing at a time. Period. Full stop. How
often do you focus on one thing at a time?
This is what we've lost. We've lost flow,
which is the dzogchen maha ati term for what
happens when you truly, truly collect your
attention. It's the state in which you're
so involved in an activity that nothing else
seems to matter. You lose track of time, and
you're retention, your depth, your absorption
are at the highest possible level. This is
what Winifred Gallagher had to say that the
skillful management of attention is the sine
qua non of the good life, and it's the key
to improving virtually everything.
I wanna give you, I wanna give you one last
piece before I, before I finish here about
the defining difference that I think we need
to take hold of if we're gonna really shift
the paradigm from reactive mode, in the face
of intense demand, from continuous work to
a intentional rhythm that you build back into
your life. When it all comes down to it, the
bottom line has to do with your ability to
delay gratification. So, what do I mean by
that?
Well, I wanna revisit just for a second this
famous study, this famous marshmallow study
and for some reason, some of you probably
already know it, it's whose study? Does anybody
know? It'll come back into my mind, but this
is a very famous study done back, originally
in the 1960s, and this is what he did. He
took four year olds, he brought them into
a room, he said to them, "If you wanna eat
this marshmallow, there's a marshmallow right
here, if you'd like to eat it, I'm gonna leave
the room. Ring the bell and I'll come back
and you can eat it. However, if you can wait
until I come back without ringing the bell,
you can have two marshmallows," having decided
that marshmallows were particularly appealing
to four year old kids. Goes out of the room,
30 percent, 70 percent of them ring the bell
within un-, under three minutes. They come
back, they have their marshmallow.
Thirty percent of them are able to delay for
the full fifteen minutes it takes him to come
back into the room. So, this is interesting,
but what's really interesting is what happens
years later when he goes back and looks at
these kids and compares, 15, 20 years later
cause this was done in the 1960s, 15 to 20,
what did the difference in the outcomes in
their lives?
And the one, the long delayers, the ones who
could stay the course, end up being more confident,
resilient, self-reliant, trusting, dependable
and persevering, and they score 120 points
higher on their SATs on average than the low
delayers. They have way more lasting friendships,
and they're far more resilient in the face
of stress. What does this tell us? It's about
attention.
It's about attention. What is it that the
great delayers do that the non-delayers don't?
They control their attention instinctively.
The great delayers -- what they're able to
do is -- they move their attention from the
object of desire to something else to purposely
distract themselves. They instinctively figure
out that if they put themselves in harm's
way, if they put themselves in sight of that
marshmallow, they will eat that marshmallow
as sure as anything will happen.
The same is true for that ping of your email.
The same is true for that text that comes
in. The same is true for when you take an
activity that feels urgent and you do that
instead of doing something that is more challenging
to do because it's more challenging to do.
Because you don't want to delay gratification.
Email is candy. Email is alcohol. Email is
cocaine. All of these are, all of these are
playing that role. And we are giving into
them because we're being run by our reptilian
brain.
We are not bringing intentionality to it;
we're not building behaviors that allow us
to do what those kids did. Now, he goes back,
Walter Mitchell is his name, Walter Mitchell
goes back and tries to understand what was
the reason that the low delayers, the high
delayers were able to do it, and he finds
an incredibly cos-, close correlation between
how co-, secure they felt with their mothers
versus the other kids who felt more insecure.
It has all to do with the early attachment
to their mothers and how well that was worked
through. Well, guess what? That's no longer
available to us. Whatever happened happened,
right?
[laughter]
So, we can't play that game. If we had bad
mothers we're gonna have to deal with it,
right?
[chuckles from audience]
So, what did he do? He did something ingenious.
What he did was, he watched what the successful
ones did, and he taught the unsuccessful ones
to do the same thing. So, he took the kids
who couldn't delay and, this is more recent,
and he taught them to move their attention
to something else. In minutes, he got them
to the point where they could wait 15 minutes
for that marshmallow. Why? Because he took
on intentional training of attention.
That's what we need to do. We need to train
our own attention just like it's a muscle.
Push past your comfort zone and recover. Try
working for 60 minutes without reading email
and the recover. And recovery, by the way,
isn't reading email.
[laughter]
Recovery is shifting out of cognitive mode,
even for a short time. So, what are the keys
to great performance? How do we understand
everything I've said to you today? This is
what it is. This is the best study ever done.
Anybody out here read Outliers? So, Malcolm
Gladwell talks about this Andrews Erickson
study in his book and he gets it half right.
The only half he misses is the important part.
The half he gets right, oh gosh, and this
is gonna be on YouTube.
[laughter]
He gets what he gets right. How about that?
What he gets is that the great performers
work harder than everybody else. That's true.
And the ten thousand hour rule, it takes ten
thousand hours to be expert and all of that,
but there's so much more interesting stuff
from this study, so here's what it is. Three
groups of violinists, ten in each group. They
ask the teachers who, to divide them from
the ones who are gonna become soloists, the
one who are really become members of orchestras;
the ones who are gonna become teachers. Those
are the least skilled.
Then he asks them to fill out a sheet every
hour for 168 hours, how important was this
activity you did during the last hour to improving
as a violinist, how difficult was it, how
enjoyable was it? And they do it for 168 hours,
this is what they foun-, this is what they
find out. Practice is, indeed, the most important
thing you can do to improve as a violinist
and to improve in anything. The top violinists
practice 24 hours a week, the less good violinists
practice 9 hours a week. Huge difference.
Big deal. Is that a surprise? That doesn't
tell you anything. Here's what's interesting
about it.
Practice, first of all, is what they say is
not only the most important, but it's the
most difficult thing they do and the least
enjoyable thing they do. That's interesting.
To be good at something you need to suffer.
You need to go to your discomfort. But this
is what's really interesting. The top groups
practice in a particular way -- three sessions
a day, an hour and a half or less, 90 minutes
or less, ultradian rhythm or less, and then
a renewal break. The bottom group practices
in the afternoon, having procrastinated, the
top group practices in the morning. Now, the
most interesting thing of all in this study
is what's the second most important thing
to improving as a violinist?
Beside practice. It's sleep. The top group
sleep an average of 8.5 hours a night, and
the second group. The, the bottom group sleeps
7.5 hours a night, the bottom group is, that's
a mess, that's wrong on that slide and the,
so it should be 8.5, 7.5, and most of us sleep
6.5 hours. So, that means we sleep 14 hours
a night less than great performers do. Is
that crazy? They sleep 14 hours more than
we do. Now, this is what I think is the conclusion
of everything I've said. It is not about staying
the course. It is not about pushing yourself
for long periods of time.
I wrote the new book, my new book, in three
90-minute sprints with a break in-between
each one. The key to your great performance
is intense effort balanced by deep recovery.
It's becoming a sprinter inside a marathon.
You live in a marathon, but the way to thrive
in that marathon is to push yourself to the
limit and then recover. Push yourself to the
limit and then recover. When you're working,
really work. When you're renewing, really
renewing. Stop living in the gray zone in-between.
Stop living there. Build back boundaries and
finish lines into your life cause that's what
will make your lives great. Thank you very
much.
[applause]